بشكل عام إذا تحدثنا عن السياسة
ه الاجتماعية الاتحاد الروسي نعم ل
من المهم دائمًا بالنسبة لنا أن يكون الطفل كذلك
في بيئة عائلية حتى يتمكن من التواجد معه
مع والديك أو أحبائك
الأقارب لذلك متى
آه، لقد تعلمنا عن مثل هذه المواقف عندما
بسبب الظروف المختلفة هناك، على سبيل المثال
انتهى الأمر بالأطفال على الأراضي الروسية
أقارب الوالدين في الموقع
أعطيت أوكرانيا التثبيت
رئيس الاتحاد الروسي فلاديمير
فلاديميروفيتش بوتين ذلك
بالضرورة يجب علينا أن نبذل قصارى جهدنا
الجهود المبذولة للحفاظ على الأسر معا
بحيث يتم تربية الأطفال بمفردهم
عائلات الدم فيما يتعلق بالمشاركة
القوارب في هذه المسألة هو بالنسبة لنا
لا تقدر بثمن لأن هذا مهم بالنسبة لنا
دولة ثالثة مستقلة لأننا
لقد قمنا بذلك بالفعل هناك
منذ وقت طويل ولكن في نفس الوقت لسوء الحظ و
العامة والأموال الغربية
وسائل الإعلام الجماهيرية
في كثير من الأحيان بطريقتي الخاصة
يبث ما يحدث نعم لا
مع إدراك أن روسيا، على سبيل المثال، هي التي تقوم بالبث
الأطفال ليس لديهم أي عوائق أمام هذا
لذا فإن أول شيء هو بالطبع بالنسبة لنا هذا
نشهد عندما نكون معا
جهد نعم عندما حسنا، في هذه الحالة
قوارب السفارة ترى كيف تتم معالجتها
وثائق كيف نلتقي هناك
أقاربنا بينما نواصل اصطحابهم معنا
الممر الإنساني وأنا جدا
ممتنة لوجودهم هنا مع
من البداية إلى الحدود ها هم
أنا أرافق PTO وأشارك بالفعل
يمكنهم أن يروا بأنفسهم ما يحدث
لأن اللحظة الثانية هي بالطبع اللحظة
الجزء الإنساني الذي يأخذه كاتر
أنفسنا، حسنا، في هذه الحالة نحن الآن
نناقش إمكانية إعادة التأهيل و
الأسر النفسية الطبية
الذين انفصلوا وبسبب هؤلاء
أو لأسباب أخرى والآن
لم شملهم وسيكون هناك
العائلات التي لديها أطفال من أوكرانيا و
أطفال من روسيا وهذا مهم جدًا بالنسبة لنا
تمكنا من دعم هذه العائلات
الأطفال بعدهم
لم شملهم
معاً